oui je sais je vais la fera ses jolies
j'ai fait un bisou maman mais bon les
bisous samedi allez salut commente une
amie christine aujourd'hui les sanctions
sont 4 10
j'ai connu christina maman et moi a
alors comment ça s'est passé
j'ai eu cet entretien génial on verra
bien ce qui va se passer mais bon enfin
au moins ça me permet de penser à autre
chose qu'à tous ses effets tu sais pas
ce que l'ex mari de 110 vient de se
remarier avec une gamine de 12 en or oui
oui enfin orange allé dire au
covoiturage à préparer les sacs des
jeunes et ne pas penser à cela
justement on parlait et christina pour
doute sur la question à skis je
comprends ça peut se comprendre ça donc
voilà son problème
oui mais tu que je te dise qu'on ne sait
pas parce qu'on s'est pas jetée à l'eau
c'est la vérité fa oui oui sérieux
bien sûr que non mais toi tu t'étais sur
eux là dessus on n'est jamais sûr moi je
l'éteins tu étais sûr sur un certaine à
100% tout voile sur la ddt et moi
j'étais à 100% certaine de vouloir des
enfants
oui il ya ça bien sûr je peux pas
imaginer c'est tout le reste qui me fait
douter je sais pas ça pour toi de voir
je suis pas juste pas la meilleure
conseillère matrimoniale
mais si justement j'ai besoin de ton
avis parce que c'est l'idée du divorce
qui ne théorise parce que j'ignore
quelles seraient les conséquences pour
elle tout pas se marier avec en tête
l'idée que tu dis force
oui c'était leader personne n'y pense
disons que une fois mariées et si on
doit divorcer
tout d'un coup tu as plus de place dans
les placards un lavabo de secours plus
drôle quand la nuit il ya des tas de
choses mais je crois qu'il faut faire ce
qu'on pense être le mieux pour les
enfants et pour soi même mais naissance
l'amour pour l'enfant lequel est en
train de manger du sable
tanner mange pas ça il ya des crottes de
chats mais ça mais c'est dégoûtant c'est
même un chat us et survivent tous et
devenir adulte comme nous